good morning
this is the uh house ways and means
uh committee executive session on
on interim study bill
on am am i getting duplicated
i'm sorry good to go now sorry about
that start again
and i wait for them you're all set
okay as chair of the house ways and
means committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020 04 this public body
is authorized to meet electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or
other electronic means we are utilizing
zoom for this electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the following
website
address https slash
zoom dot u s slash j slash
nine three zero zero eight three three
six
five seven or dialing one of the
following foul
phone numbers 1 312
626 679
or 1 929 205
609 b providing public access
of notice of the necessary information
for
accessing the meeting we previously gave
notice to the public of the necessary
information for accessing this meeting
including how to access it using zoom or
telephonically
this information is printed in the house
cattle
calendar c providing a mechanism
for the public to alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access
if anyone does have a problem please
call 271-3600
or email h c
d adjoining the meeting if the public is
unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
jennifer four is the meeting host and
additional staff providing support are
christina dyer and joel anderson
this is a work and executive session on
bills referred to the ways and means
committee for interim study
the public hearings for these bills
occurred many months ago
and work sessions were seriously delayed
by the covet epidemic
at a work or executive session only
committee members may speak
unless a committee member requests a
specific
audience member to add some information
we have not yet received
in that case the staff will make that
possible
anyone communicating by phone including
committee members has to press star nine
in order to ask to speak
pursuant to house rule 43 b
executive sessions may take place
throughout the committee
deliberations we will take up each bill
in order
and discuss and vote
copies of the interim study bills have
been posted on the main page of the
general court website under the heading
remote
meetings please note that all votes are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
the clerk will call the roll for
attendance
representative here
i'm on your mouth representative carrick
i'm here
by myself representative southworth
malloy clerk is here alone
representative schamberg i am here and
my wife is wandering around the house
he's muted
she has to be unmuted you're alone
representative bunker i am here my wife
is in the room but i'm listening on
headphones
representative marlow i'm here in
swansea by myself
representative griffith here on my own
representative stringham here by myself
representative major heir impasto
representative hillary
[Applause]
[Music]
president in salem by myself
representative edwards uh representative
edwards uh my wife's in background
i tried selling fundraising tickets to
this and they didn't go well
lange representative lang i'm in my car
in boston massachusetts and i am alone
representative bursting i'm in beautiful
nottingham new hampshire in my home
office
there are one two three four five six
eighteen people present two
absent thank you
on so we definitely have a quorum
on sorry um
uh i'd like to suggest that everybody
mute themselves when they're not going
to speak i know it's hard to remember to
unmute yourself again
but i'm at least getting a bunch of
static in the background
and before we start i wanted to point
out that today is the 11th of september
the 19th anniversary of the world's
worst terrorist attack on our soil
i would like to start with a minute of
silence for the almost 3 000 lives
and 25 000 injured in that attack many
damages
this
thank you i'm sure everyone remembers
where they were
when that happened i was on the way into
concord for
so now we will proceed with
117 increasing exemptions
under the interest and dividends tax and
decreasing the total amount of research
and development tax credits
against business taxes on
representative uh
no on i was actually going to
make a motion for this one
on and but we're in work session
first i'd forgotten so
does anybody have anything
to to
bring up about this bill we've
we put it off last year
and this year covid has
really killed anything that we might
have done about it so
um representative brahmay
uh has his physical hand up i think
here yes yes i do
okay representative
um the republican caucus had a
discussion on this
on this bill and uh we think that we
should move
for consideration for legislation for
next year or a similar bill
um we feel it's been a long time since
the exemptions have been
increased and that we we feel that
even even with the virus and lower
revenues
we could even put a date out certain uh
for the potential reduction in revenue
but
if the bill includes the reduction in
the r d tax credits that should cover
that anyway
so um we still support the concept
as a caucus thank you
and from our side
we had um decided tentatively that we
would
would want to recommend not recommend
for further legislation on this
tax covers an unknown number of people
who
could use that exemption on
that are retired and very low income
and but it also covers all of the
wealthy people that it was originally
developed
to to uh tax
um a 100 years ago on
the dividends and the interests were
both
owned almost entirely by the very
wealthy
in the state and on
for them this would be very little money
but
for us with our revenues in very bad
shape it could uh
mean the difference between a lot of
services that
those people in the lower income
brackets especially but the whole
society needs
um
and the and we also don't know what the
effect of that could be on
some of the smaller businesses that use
the
research and development tax credit
though it is
quite small for each business
and um there we have not been
able yet to get a realistic
evaluation of that tax credit
and we also haven't been able to find
data to
figure out how many people
are in those two categories i mentioned
for the interest and dividends tax
the retired that are trying to live off
of personal savings that they made
and most of which is in
interest and dividends and and the
very wealthy for whom their interest in
dividends is a small part of
what revenue they bring in every year
so and then there are also other
um bills that
could be under consideration in the
future that
would would um
change these exemptions in the process
of doing another tax reform
so not a
broad-based one but a
a larger one than this contemplates
so that is um
that's been pretty much
the way we felt on the other side of
this i don't know whether anybody else
wants to
mr chairman representative lang i'm
representative lang
and i think yes
go ahead obviously i have a vested
interest in this bill
um in that i was one of the sponsors of
the prime sponsor for this bill
um one of the things i will say is that
if if this bill is moved for
recommendation
uh going forward for further legislation
i anticipate filing this bill but i
would not do that
until the second session of next year
and the main reason being is so we
wanted to recognize what the revenues
would look like and the impact
um but again i think that you know these
are the kind of bills we want to see
that are net zero to the state you know
the idea being that
while we're giving a tax break and
allowing our citizens to be able to keep
more income that they earn at the same
time
we're paying for that by pulling back on
subsidies
for businesses that should be paying
taxes so i think that
you know this is the exact kind of bill
we want to see in the future
for moving forward if we're going to be
lowering taxes is doing it with an
offset
so that we see there's no impact
potentially on on
government services so i would hope that
considering that we we'd be able to
recommend that this legislation move
forward
in the future sessions and and i'll
commit to filing in my second session of
next year
thank you mr chairman thank you i think
on
representative yes you've got now got
your hand up virtually it's easier for
i'm trying to watch the side panel and
half
of representatives bursting ames brownie
okay am i yeah you hear me now yeah good
job
okay um yeah uh
i think the half of this bill that uh
that increases exemptions is
is something that needs to happen
to the tax credit the particular tax
credit here
in this bill um i
i think is uh it's it's it that
that linkage i think is uh
is not ready for action and i think we
need more information i think uh
representative
amy spoke to that um i think we're
poorly informed on
the degree to which that
that tax credit is important i know that
the the business and industries
association
i came to our hearing on this bill which
was way back
in late in 2019 i think
uh yes who speak in opposition to the
bill because
they believe that the tax credit is
important
um so um so
i don't think going forward with a
recommendation
that legislation has called for whatever
the language is that
that would be used is appropriate for
this bill
in its current form and would
definitely be looking at the possibility
of linking the
tax exemption
changes that are needed in the ind
tax to something else that would pay for
those exemption changes
thank you representative stringham has
thank you madam chair um uh
in general um you know i like the
structure of the bill the fact that it's
uh trying to be revenue neutral i do
know the
the r d uh tax credit program
is um is important to remain
as part of the state it is uh just
having one is an incentive
for certain businesses and so we have a
checkbox that we have a program
i do think there may not be much benefit
to the program of having the program at
2 million as opposed to 7 million
so and i do think that the
interest in dividend tax
could use an increase in the exemption
so
in general i do like the structure of
this um
you know overall you know i am concerned
about uh the quoted recession the impact
on the budget
the uh
underfunded pension which exceeds five
billion right now
and uh in our efforts to restructure how
we fund education
uh and these are all this bill is a drop
in the bucket compared to the
size of the financial considerations
hey jerry can you lean in closer to your
microphone and it's really hard for me
to hear
up okay well
that was that was most i just said in
general i agree with the structure of
this i don't mind
legislation going forward on either
either year
uh next term i i am certain that we
would have to have
more analysis to make sure that it's
revenue neutral i like the fact that it
it's offset i do think it's a small bill
compared to
major financial challenges that we will
have
uh in making more progress in pensions
and uh and the changing role of how we
fund education in the state
that's they're my comments
thank you representative oleri wants to
talk
yeah as people know i'm very reluctant
to speak in public
um if we're going to
push this forward i would suggest that
we do it for a first year bill
so we could discuss it over the summer
that's the only modification i would
make
how and when tim puts it forward it's
it's up to him but uh this is a bill
as is the other one worthy of
considerable
discussion and doing it in a short
period of time
may not do either of those two bills
justice
i mean we have the option of deferring
it
or holding it for interim study so
that's two cents thank you
bye
thank you well yeah i'm still on
on we do
know that the interest and dividends
have increased considerably since 2016.
the stock market is the only part of the
economy that's happy at this point
and in 2016 according to the fiscal note
uh this would have cost us a little bit
over a million dollars
net so um or
the exemption would have had to be cut
down further
we are still going to be in recession
at least in a recession on our revenues
and a recession probably in
on our economy next year
and so i welcome representatives
lange's offer to put it in in the second
year
when we have finished the major work
we're going to have to do to try to
figure out how to keep this government
together
in the first year and maybe moved around
different parts of our tax structure i
have no idea
whether that is going to happen or not
but on but we had to
full with some of the adjust the number
of revenue sources
in the great recession and this one's
worse
so i don't know whether we're going to
cut our government down
into shreds with no safety net or we're
going to
find have to find revenues or whether
the federal government will finally bail
us out
on so um
[Music]
i think by the second year things should
be more stable and we'll be able to
to start to try to figure out where we
are we'll also have i think
some information by then from from the
dra
um we uh
if ours if the
issue of not recommended for further
study passes then
on or if it doesn't pass
i would would like the alternative
viewpoint to be included in the blurb
because
we're only allowed to write one blurb
so um and
as you know uh whatever we do now is not
definitive for next year
we could say we want to do this and the
people who are here next year
hate it or and and nobody puts it in
or we could uh or
we could say we don't want to do it and
the people
next term think okay this is a better
idea than we thought even if they're the
same people
so um it's not definitive
it's just a suggestion until next year
but i personally would like to go ahead
with making a recommendation since no
one else wants to talk
uh for uh not recommended for
further for future legislation
but within the blurb section
saying that um that once the
economic situation is stabilized
uh that at least until the economic
situation
and but explaining from our side why
that we need to get a better idea
of this tax credit which i think can be
done
without the bill in place
on by the tax expenditure committee
even though the senate cut it down to
and hopefully by then we'll we'll have
we'll be able to find something perhaps
from a national level
about on the distribution
of income that is hit by this
this peculiar tax that we have and other
people don't
so um that may be
available in some of in itep or
the tax foundation or somebody that
could do it
um so i would like to make the motion
not recommended for further further
legislation future legislation sorry
that's the motion
it's not recommended for future
legislation um
[Music]
and see where we are on a vote on that
from somebody that's not muted
representative schamberg
i second that motion madam chair i have
a question uh
uh uh of order
[Music]
um it is uh whether we're in an
executive session
i think you said at the beginning
jen do you know do we have to say
specifically that we're in the executive
session
i think it's it's helpful just to
clarify
from okay but there's no
we've never done the two combined before
we've always tried to wait a day
at least uh so i'm calling us
into executive session i don't think
that does that require a roll call vote
or something
no good and i want to make the
the motion of not recommended for
future study for hb
117 fn with my with the
caveats i was mentioning so
representative schamberg second set
motion madam chair
thank you so
further
you're still muted did it again i did it
again
i thought you know i made it myself that
i muted myself
well well when we went to executive
session i'd muted
but then anyway i i think i mean i agree
with what you're saying
uh i'm still going to vote the other way
i understand you know even our caucus
understands the fiscal situation we're
in
and that uh if this bill does get move
you know brought forth in the first
session uh
that we we've been looking closely at
what the revenues look like
we're not going to take any action if if
we're really in a hole
um i think it's safe to say but yeah i
think we just want to make statement
that we
uh again this is all this really is it's
making a statement i mean it's
i mean if even if it's uh if it's
uh you know more recommended you know
recommended no
someone can still file the bill so uh
just so you know but we just want to
make sure everybody understands that
we're sensitive to
the state of our revenues and that we'd
be very cautious
about you know and as as representative
luery said
even when we filed the first time we we
could just
interim study it and continue to monitor
revenues
as time watches next next time that's
all yeah
just i i feel a little bit
difficult about doing a
but i would i would be
uh quite willing to share the the
tentative blurb with representative
lange
can we move the question yes on
uh representative i think if you
move the question don't we have to all
just raise your hand
i'm in favor of moving the question
i do think you have to i'll vote for all
your votes i'm sorry you do
yeah even that one oh okay
uh i was and so let's
let's uh the clerk will call a roll on
moving
if i may make a suggestion
i wonder if representative major might
withdraw his motion
and allow you to go ahead um
i would rather presumably with the vote
thank you very much
so i would like to ask the clerk to call
a role
on the motion of not recommended for
future
legislation representative ames
yes representative carrick
yes representative southworth
yes clerk votes yes
representative schamberg yes
representative tucker yes representative
bunker
yes representative gamarlo
yes representative griffith
no
zlatman
[Applause]
well
i still couldn't understand
representative stringham again
representative major no
is in hillary no
representative abrami no
representative de set no
representative lang vote snow
representative bursting
no representative almi
yes
i don't remember how many of us there
eighteen it's eighteen vote is
nine to nine right
so that motion goes down
madam chair if i make a motion to
approve for future legislation
given the failure of the previous vote
i'll second that representative berstein
seconds day
[Applause]
uh i'm sorry who made the motion
representative
just for a point of order here what
happens if this motion doesn't pass
um then we could reconsider another
motion
i don't think jen do you remember i
don't ever
remember an interim study going in as
on no recommendation i don't know if
they'd take that motion
we have three staff that are on the call
yes and content should stay with us can
can
someone check that out even if we move
on to the next
next bill and come back to this if it
comes out tied again
sure can someone check that out yes
madam chair guys ask supportive order
question yes
so again the if i understand a
motion to recommend for future
legislation um
all that chair says is all that motion
really means is that in concept we agree
with the idea of the bill
and that the bill could be brought
forward it doesn't necessarily mean the
exact language of the current bill
should be brought forward
um at least that's how i've dealt with
it in previous committees so i'm
you know i guess i'm trying to make a
clarification that i believe that that's
what the intent is that
we're just saying as a committee we like
the general idea of this bill and should
be brought forward
in some form and be dealt with again is
uh
that's a fair representation yes on
[Music]
i in particular do not want to vote for
something that
on looks like we might be
on taking away revenue
which the bill itself did does do
so and we have
and and i'm not sure whether we have
represented bursting
for a first time i think so i'm
representing schamberg seems to have put
his hand up first
uh madam chair i didn't take my hand
down from the other one i'm sorry
oh okay so representative bursting
yeah uh thank you madam chair i want to
thank
uh representative ames for reminding us
that the
business community did chime in on this
and was against
uh this i and i know the hearing was a
long time ago
so i'd like to remind the committee
that in addition to the business
community we also heard from some
retirees and from some civilians for
lack of a better word
and they spoke about how this pushes
seniors out on the risk curve
and how this would be of help to seniors
on a fixed income
uh i i i recall that and i'd like to
bring that to everyone's
the forefront of your memory as well
this bill
or this has merit and i thank
representative lang for bringing it
forward and i
certainly will support it and ask for
thank you on
representative ames
yeah i think i'm unmuted
am i yes you are um okay
yeah i i just wanted to respond to
representative berstein's
comment and point out that
about the same time as this bill was
coming through
the review process in 2019
there was another bill that i was the
sponsor of which was a bill
to extend the interest and dividends tax
to capital gains and included in that
bill
was a significant more significant
actually
increase in the exemptions for
individuals responding directly to the
concern
that the representative bursting just
spoke spoke to and that a number of
people in the hearing on this bill also
spoke to and i agree with that did
happen
so i i want to repeat that i
am very much for changing those
exemptions they're very old and very
small
but the linkage in this bill is clear
to a pay for option that i don't
support at this time based on the
information i have
and that's why i cannot vote for
a recommendation for future legislation
on um on this bill
not just in its present form but in
terms of what it stands for it stands
for a specific change in one particular
business tax credit that i don't have
enough information on
to support so that's i
just wanted to clarify that thank you
representative elmi um i did hear back
from um house clerk paul smith
um and you certainly need to vote on the
pending motion
um and if no recommendation is
the only option it is something that can
be done
um still be just one state one interim
study statement
um that can include both sides um
thought on the recommendation the lack
so it would be one statement but we
could have two paragraphs sort of
it probably wouldn't be two paragraphs
technically
[Music]
yes side said and the other side said
yeah okay okay
well shall we vote on um
[Music]
it's been more than seconded yes
the clerk seems to be having to get
something
i don't know if you could hear we're
calling the vote
on recommended for further legislation
recommended for first future or
legislation what your legislation is
your legislation move my representative
lang seconded by
representative burstein exactly
representative carrick no
clerk votes no representative schamberg
no representative tucker
no was that a bunker
no representative camarlo
no representative griffith
no
representative major yes
representative valerie yes
yes representative edwards
edwards votes yes representative lang
representative lang just to be aware
i've been joined in the car but my
daughter megan
and i vote yes representative burstein
yes representative army
seven years eleven nays
okay um does anyone
wish to make a further
motion of reconsideration or
there's no recommendation
i'm sorry there's two people speaking at
once representatively i don't know
who the other person was uh can we go
forward
with uh no recommendation at this point
or does
if if no one wishes to make a
um a reconsideration motion which i
i mean there's a different vote count
now so i mean a reconsideration could
possibly be successful um
but someone would have to move that
chair point of order yes so again i
think for a motion to reconsider you
would have to have somebody in the
affirmative side who voted in the
prevailing
side to be able to make the motion so
the only motion that could be
emotionally considered is my motion to
approve the bill for future legislation
the other one failed and there is no
affirmative side
so at this point i think we're stuck at
a no recommendation
uh position um that is
not true inside committees as i
understand it
jen do you remember i mean
i'm not an expert in this area i don't
want to yeah and to be
yeah well and you'd have to check with
the clerk again but my memory is that
they told us that
that um you don't
you don't follow that role inside of
committees but
um but my memory is based on being
trained a few years ago so
well um we've spent 35 minutes on this
yes we have i know and we weren't going
to spend much time on it
i think that you're you're
trying to sort of dredge up further
action i think we've reached a
resolution on that last vote
i know we just put a blurb out saying
without recommendation and give both
sides
yeah i think that's satisfactory i'd i'd
be satisfied with that also
yeah if that's okay with the people
okay do we we vote on no recommendation
okay so on the hb
117 will go forward without
recommendation
i hope we won't be told that was the
wrong thing to do
and um representative
lang
who just got unconnected representative
do you want to write a short statement
in
or or representative majors there's
someone else
yeah i'll take care of that
and then send it to me i'll send you
mine and
okay mine
jordan has to leave at 11 right
right all right we've only got 10
minutes
did not expect this to take this long um
so i think we're together on this
next one yeah yeah we are actually
together on this next one
i i want to uh introduce for discussion
purposes we are out of executive session
i would like to introduce for example on
discussion purposes
house bill 1567 fna relative to
worldwide combined reporting for unitary
businesses
under the business profits tax on
and
representative major had told us
that they would be willing to send this
forward for
future legislation on
with as a study committee and on
the our caucus had already
agreed that we wanted to spend it
forward as a study committee
also so i don't know if we have to
discuss
discuss it right now but is there anyone
who wants to
talk about this further i want to thank
representative schamberg for bringing
this forward by the way
you guys didn't want to hear my talk
today right
oh and representative abrami wants to
talk reps and wolverine is trying to
remind us i think he has 10 minutes so
let's
be real i'll be very quick yeah when you
say committee are we
going to talk about a commission or a
legislative committee
a legislate well the commission we had
on
proportion was very good and we had we
had a lot of
experts on that as well but only a few
we wanted to be full committee right
you're right we can get
into the commission into the kabul
committee right yeah
okay that's all um representative
chamber did you
um representative do you want to say
something about this
or are you just reminding us about the
time
both and what i said previously about
introducing is the first session so we
got
plenty of time to give us the due
respect yeah
okay representative schamberg you
you're planning on introducing with a
the study committee is much better than
the commission yes
yeah commission
generally is going to take two years
probably to do it so okay
so um this
though it's up to if he puts the bill in
it's up to
representative schamberg to shape it
again
um so can i have a motion
uh i want i want us to go into executive
session representative ames
can you make a motion sure i i move
that this bill what's the number
uh that's 15 66 67
that house bill 1567 be
uh with a recommendation uh
that is recommended for future
legislation
good on the motion
is recommended for future legislation
made by representatives seconded by
representative abrami
representative ames yes
representative carrick yes
representative southworth yes
clerk vote yes representative schamberg
you have to unmute representative
yes representative bunker
yes representative
yes representative griffith
yes representative lockman
representative stringham yes
yes sorry about that thank you
representative already yes
representative abrami yes representative
giusette
yes representative edwards
no representative lang
[Applause]
it is 17 yes one
no thank you the vote being
17 to 1. uh hb
1567 will go
on on the calendar as recommended for
future legislation and let me say
yes representative major yeah and
that's good voted this way because i
don't think there's any of us
really understand the full extent of
this bill
we need to study it in order to be able
to understand the good part and the bad
part and what it will do for us and what
will
not do for us and if we want to move
forward
with this type of legislation so voting
for a study committee is the right thing
to do
thank you representative only wants a
yeah real quickly um those of you who
know kim rice uh
she's grandma first time and you can see
the smile on her face
you should see her smile so make sure
next week
mimi her nickname
thank you jordan that's much appreciated
on to representative major
i think that we do um
we we definitely need to study this
further and we have
some resources that we can start to
share among ourselves more
on about this even before the term
and i
hope that on any anything that we can
think of
that might be good
to do in a recession uh in this
particular recession
to recover our revenues to some extent
on this will not help during the
recession but it could
it could help the whole state later
uh and we might both
all we might agree bipartisanly that it
did
or it may not work so we really do have
to study it
thank you um this is
the last session
um of this committee
and so i'm about to thank you all
we didn't get to do much of a of a party
this year
but i do want to thank you all for for
the work that
everybody has been doing on this and
contributing to
in lately in very difficult
circumstances
but on i think we did a lot of good work
in the first
first uh year of the term and
on we had started to in the second year
of the term
and i hope that a lot of us will be
getting back together again
in january i just want to say something
if i could uh madam chairman
is that on june 11 we had a session at
rittermore
if you notice this was only one bill
that showed partis uh
nonpartisan and that was the bill that
we
put in for the revenues yes
we agreed as a full committee
the only way we could do that is the
work that we did for two months
as separate caucuses and then you and i
would get together and find out what are
the pros and cons
and what are the issues and then bring
them back to the caucus and so
finally we come up with something we
agreed on
no other committee has done that so
everybody should be recommended to
complement themselves
what we've done because to be an
effective legislator you have to know
how to
negotiate and you have to know how to
compromise
just just add my voice uh compliments to
our two
leaders from each side of our committee
and each side probably is not the best
reference but uh
but uh thank you representative major
and thank you representative army
yes yes i want to echo that
and to but to complement every single
person on this committee for
working together on this and it became
something of a wonder and
maybe a scandal to some that that the
ways and means committee was doing that
across the legislature and i hope that
we can
continue doing that in the future there
are things that we will
always disagree with but you're right
and i've noticed and work together
is is really important so
thank you all thank you thank you
jordan i i have mary
representative griffin on the phone uh
via my computer here and she's listening
and she wanted to say
um uh her piece go ahead mary
i'm so sorry i couldn't join in earlier
but i have a migraine headache and i can
barely see
oh dear oh mary
yeah i feel bad for you
yeah i hope that
they don't continue um
so so mary also has been much
appreciated on the committee
and and i think that
that pretty much does it for
this final session of our committee this
term
well and i hope we
see each other next time okay
bye-bye so see each other again